Real - Life Castaway : Philip Quarll, Marooned in 1675.
In 1725, Edward Dorrington - an 18th - century trader from Bristol, England -...
...rowed from his anchored ship toward an emerald green Pacific island with a craggy,...
...irregular and dangerous shoreline.
Landing on the lush, beautiful, and supposedly uninhabited island,...
...he found a single hand - fashioned thatched hut situated near a deep forest.
Soon the island's sole resident,...
...an old Englishman with a flowing white beard and hair covering his shoulders and naked belly appeared.
With a tame monkey at his side,...
...the old man prepared a dinner for his welcome guests - soup,...
...meat and fish - set out on a tablecloth made of a ship's sail and served up in plates of gleaming seashell.
The delicious meal was a masterpiece of simplicity,...
...created by a man keenly in touch with his environment.
The castaway was Philip Quarll, a former sailor, trader, husband, and vagabond.
He had presided for 50 years as solitary monarch over his tiny island of monkeys...
...and pomegranate fields far off the coast of Mexico.
Though his life had been lonely,...
...he explained that he had ceased thinking of himself as a victim and was not in need of rescue.
Quarll had no intention of abandoning his island cell.
Over a half - century,...
...the shipwrecked stranger had become a self - sufficient hermit.